hey 42 here today's video is brought to
you by the fantastic
the great courses plus learn more at the
end of the video
did you know there are an estimated 40
billion planets
in the milky way galaxy that could
support alien life
that means for every one in five stars
there is an earth-like planet
currently in orbit with the nearest
being only 12 light years away from us
in space terms that's essentially around
the corner
therefore it is possible that far closer
than you'd think
on another world very similar to ours is
another life form
very similar to you watching a video
very similar to this one and right now
it is hitting the subscribe button
our universe is home to an incredible
array of planets
some of which may astonish you planets
are formed when dense
disks of gas and dust start encircling
young
stars when this happens the gas and dust
slowly accumulate and through the
process known as accretion
a brand new planet is formed with its
own
peculiarities bizarre qualities and
sometimes
horrors many of these planets have
features we can relate to
and are similar to those in our own
solar system that we can observe using
low-tech telescopes
but others are so strange that they
boggle the mind
for example there is hat p1b
a planet so bizarre it threatens to
change the way we think about planet
formation
puffed up by heat seeping into the
planet's interior
this so-called puffy planet is almost
half the size of jupiter but has a
density
lighter than cork which quite literally
means
it could float in water if we had a
large enough swimming pool to dunk it
into
or consider j1407b
a planet with so many circumplanetary
rings
that they have an outer radius of 90
million
kilometers 640 times that
of saturn in other words it's saturn
but on cocaine or finally there is
g-u-p-s-c-b
a planet with an orbit of 80 000 years
leaving you with a fair wait for your
birthday but those are just some of the
strange planets what about the
frightening ones
the ones that make us look up at the
stars and feeling unsettling
ominous sensation the one so dangerous
and so creepy
you would never ever want to encounter
them as doing so
would spell certain death well
to begin with what if i was to tell you
that there
are some worlds that are quite literally
the living dead orbiting the star
psr b1257 plus 12
unsettlingly known as lich are three
exoplanets which are planets outside our
solar system
these zombie worlds individually known
as poltergeist
drauga and phobitol exist
in one of the most uninhabitable
terrifying
corners of the universe and the reason
for that
is quite simple lich their star
is a pulsar an undead
star that constantly leaks horrifying
quantities of electromagnetic radiation
from its core
such stars are even thoughts to be the
possible source of
ultra high energy cosmic rays this
constant bombardment of radiation from
the undead star's core
saturates each of its orbiting zombie
planets
meaning that if you were to step foot on
any one of them
you would essentially be microwaved
alive
but if you think that's bad there is a
planet where your death would be so
violent it gives a whole new meaning to
the chinese torture
ling chi otherwise known as death by a
thousand cuts
the extrasolar planet hd hd189733b
is beset by winds so frightening they
are difficult to even comprehend
at 5400 miles per hour
these winds blow across the entire
planet seven times the speed
of sound and over 30 times faster than
hurricane katrina
but before you think your death would
come at the hands of being blown into
something solid and spiky at such speeds
the winds alone would not cause your
death
you would meet your end when they
combine with something much
much worse with silicate rich clouds
teeming in the skies and the close
proximity to its host
star this planet reigns
a lot and when it does it rains
molten glass blown by the max 7 winds
this molten glass rains sideways
and would rip your body to shreds in a
hail of razor blades
similar and perhaps more frightening is
the exoplanet
ogle tr56b the planet
that reigns molten iron the most distant
planet in the sagittarius
constellation ogle tr-56 is
theorized to have clouds made not for
water
but from iron atoms so whilst being torn
to shreds by molten glass
might disturb you just imagine being
encased in a downpour of molten iron
sealing you in a distorted pompeii-like
statue
for all eternity but there's more
what if i was to tell you that there's
an exoplanet that is basically
a living hell called kepler-70b
it is a planet that actually spent time
inside a star now whilst that might
sound like every teenage boy's dream
it's far more like a horror movie than
you'd imagine
kepler-70b was plunged into the star's
envelope
which is a part of every star not
gravitationally bound to the star's core
and formed by dense stellar wind
as this was during the star's red giant
phase the dying phase when the star
is at its largest but with a cooler
surface temperature
kepler 70b survived
but it was left with one deadly
attribute
it is now almost 7000 degrees
celsius on the surface in other words
it's a burning inferno that is hotter
than the surface of the
sun it would quite literally burn you
and everyone around you to
ash in seconds but not all terrifying
planets
are little-known worlds thousands of
light years from earth
some are much closer to home than you'd
expect
take jupiter for example a planet which
as you'll soon learn belongs in a cheesy
disaster movie because
it has dozens of incredible ways it can
kill you
made of hydrogen and helium trying to
land on jupiter is like trying to land
on a cloud or mist
as it doesn't actually have an outer
crust it's just gas
all the way through but if for the sake
of argument you did attempt to land on
it
you would encounter a number of blood
curdling problems
your first issue would naturally be the
lack of oxygen which would starve your
lungs causing a slow fish out of water
death as you agonizingly gasp for breath
but 155 miles down would be where your
real problems would begin
rotating faster than any other planet in
our solar system
with a day lasting only 9.5 hours
jupiter
is home to a hurricane twice the size of
earth with 270 mile per hour storm
speeds that's constantly spinning
and has so far lasted for 340
years sounds bad well
if you managed to survive that you would
be cut off from the outside world
because jupiter's enormous all-consuming
atmosphere would absorb
all radio waves and distress signals
calling for help
but i wouldn't worry because you'd soon
be disintegrated by its 3
371 degree celsius temperature
so hot it could melt the metal with the
highest melting point in the universe
tungsten and all this before you even
made it halfway
through the planet but even closer to
home
is another planet potentially even more
horrifying
venus commonly thought of as earth's
closest neighbor
although scientists now think that could
actually be mercury
is similar in many ways but even more
dissimilar
and disturbing in many others covered in
rolling dunes
and mountains venus is also home to
gigantic swarms
of old lava flows but these wouldn't be
the main source of your problems
you see the atmosphere on a venus is so
thick so poisonous and so hot
it would kill you in three different
ways at the same time
hot enough to melt lead you would burn
alive
pressure's so great you would be
immediately crushed and an atmosphere so
toxic it not only smells like rotten
eggs
it would have you breathing huge
quantities of carbon dioxide
and you would even be exposed to
sulfuric acid
that rains down in the upper atmosphere
melting your skin
off your bones but perhaps
even more chilling is that venus
is theorized to have been habitable as
recently
as one billion years ago although the
planet has since been devastated
by a runaway greenhouse effect so
who knows what secrets or life
may lurk beneath its sand speaking of
secrets
there is a planet that exists that is
almost as
old as the universe itself
at 13 billion years old and formed one
billion years after the universe began
the genesis planet otherwise known as
psr
b162026b or methuselah
is three times older than earth
this ancient world exists in a strange
and unlikely part of the universe
orbiting two burned-out stars within a
densely clustered
core of a globular star cluster
formed so quickly after the big bang and
thriving in such a busy region of space
this ancient and mysterious planet
has been witness to a history that we
cannot possibly imagine
what has it seen and who or what
may have visited it but the most
mysterious
and creepy worlds aren't necessarily the
most ancient
there is another planet known to be in
our solar system
that has never been seen by man
i am speaking of course about the eerily
named planet x
arguably the most elusive invisible
planet in the universe
because it's in our solar system yet we
can't see it
deep beyond pluto it has been theorized
by many astronomers
that there is an enormous planet that
traces a bizarre orbit in the outer
reaches of our solar system
whilst no direct observation of the
planet has been made
detailed computer simulations and
mathematical models
all point to its existence all that's
known is that it's in the kuiper belt
where the planet is suspected to be
dwarf planets and smaller debris and
objects are clustering together
following something much much
larger like remoras swimming under the
belly of an enormous shark
but the most unique dangerous
and deadly planet in the universe
it's not where you'd expect what if i
were to tell you
that there is a planet where the
atmosphere is continually pumped with
poisonous gas
where we know more about the surrounding
planets in its solar system
then we know the secrets of its oceans
and where the species of life on its
surface greedily consume each other
with the most dominant of all
slaughtering its own kind in droves
it's a planet where you can be murdered
shot stabbed enslaved tortured
starved suffocated burned eaten alive
frozen ravaged by disease or infection
or coronavirus and all in all killed
in more varied evil and horrifying
and excruciating ways than anywhere else
in the entire known universe
and you're living on that planet right
now
so next time you look up into the stars
and start feeling an unsettling ominous
feeling
remember you're no safer here on earth
thanks for watching
but one way you can forget about the
dangers of the world
is by indulging in the comfort of
learning from your own home
with the great courses plus who have
kindly sponsored today's video
i really do love the great courses plus
i have used it for years to enrich my
knowledge
on all the topics i bring you on this
channel i sit down to enjoy a lecture or
two
every single day in between writing i've
almost finished a fascinating course
the foundations of western civilization
i've long been interested in ancient
greek roman and british history
but this course takes you through the
tapestry of our time
from ancient sumer to the british empire
and
links these great civilizations together
in a way that you've probably never been
aware of
it is taught by one of the most candid
and learned professors i have
ever had the joys of watching thomas fx
noble the great courses plus is a
subscription on-demand video learning
service with top-notch lectures
and courses from top professors from the
ivy league and other great universities
globally and experts in places like
national geographic the smithsonian
and the culinary institute of america
through your subscription you get access
to a huge library of over 11 000 video
lectures
about anything that interests you
science maths history literature
or even how to cook play chess or become
a better photographer
right now the great courses plus is
giving my viewers a great
offer of a free trial you can show your
support for my channel
by clicking on the link in the
description below to start your free
trial today
thank you